[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett I'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting
we're gonna go to uncharted territory
unknown zones of old putting your phone
in airport mode that's right well I'm
putting my phone in airplane mode well I
I like to just preemptively get it done
on the before I start crossing the
tarmac man so in the airport you got to
get that Airport Wi-Fi you know what I
know you're right but I can't not call
it Airport mode because for some reason
I've always done that you know one time
I tweeted about the problem with airport
Wi-Fi the free every airport has free
Wi-Fi but it never works sometimes you
got to watch a video and well but I
tweeted about that and then Ashton
Kutcher the couch man tweeted back at me
and was like don't use don't use Airport
Wi-Fi incredibly insecure or incredibly
unsecure he was like telling me that I'm
insecure he was saying that it wasn't it
was an unsecured Network as it knows
you're insecure and then he pointed me
towards some app that like Cisco Systems
something he was probably involved in
which is some SAP that you use on your
phone secure and Ashton's advice for you
no no I'm I'm sure that any period
expert you think he was did I turn your
volume up by accident no it's just when
you touch the volume of anything you
know we see somebody adjust sorry guys
we're adjusting all types of thinks
today we're gonna just what we wants
like when you see somebody just like
their shirt and then you kind of
naturally well maybe I need my shirt I
need just my hair we also moved your
phone out because we heard you well we
heard one person we read one person
complaining about I don't want the phone
in there so fine it's not in here we
just want you if it's a freaking break
happy but I got question Ashton without
question yelling no I'm not questioning
that I believe wholeheartedly that
airport Wi-Fi is probably a bad idea and
anybody knows anything about Wi-Fi
security
that kind of thing would tell you don't
get on a public Wi-Fi if you want to if
you care about your information but I'm
just thinking that Ashton Kutcher's
probably also personally involved in the
product that he was pushing nothing
wrong with that I'm not talking about an
insider traded you reply to Ashton
Kutcher no cuz I cuz I got to the tweet
like two days late I saw like whoa
you're on a two-day flight no it just
happened to see like sometimes I go in
and I click on I click on who's replied
to me and I click on verify to be like
ok
who what verified people are interested
in me today for a self-image when you
need a little pick-me-up and I saw
Ashley Kutcher I was like oh yeah the
guy once you push him in the stomach
remember that I didn't did I punch him
in this light you poked him in the
stomach with a pencil or something I
think we we well we we did a misleading
thumbnail right at some point about our
meeting with Ashton Kutcher you can look
that up on that was on a good mythical
morning channel before good mythical
morning existed mm-hmm
one of our first la not first but one of
the fledgling LA visits we had a meeting
with Ashton Kutcher Airport Wi-Fi
security expert because we wanted to
make sure that we stayed secure in and
all of our flight endeavors but I but
you know I also an actor he's probably
sincere okay so this is a rabbit hole
episode we're gonna go down the rabbit
hole that's what I was trying to say
uncharted territory oh I need to put my
phone in the airport mode too because I
have not done it and in in going back to
that maybe one of us needs to be
available you ever thought about that
you ever thought about the times we go
into airplane mode when we record it in
your biscuit we go into airplane mode
when we shoot GMM but but there's always
someone that like if if a loved one
needs to reach us I mean it's easy to
reach us through other people true that
but you know that there's there's this
thing that if you go to a a concert or
comedy show or some sort of venue
they've got that pocket now that you put
your phone in there taking people's
phones and like no you keep your phone
but they give you a pocket to put it in
yeah and then they have the key so you
can't
you do distracting things during the
show to ruin other people's experience
like be filming or be texting or talking
but the thing that I don't understand is
and you can go outside in order to use
your phone but I don't know how you know
if if somebody's trying to get in touch
with you and I don't think they can what
if what if you made the bonehead move of
like leaving an embarrassing ringtone
turned all the way up or there's an
alarm that's gonna go off and now it's
in a bag it's not a soundproof bag well
I'm sure I'm sure they've I kind of want
to go to a show just to experience this
phone satchel I have what's it called do
you remember
phone satchel sounds good enough that's
our version we're partnering my Aston I
have many questions about phone satchel
number one is what I just raised is what
happens when something when it does
happen to your phone but it's not
silenced but the other thing is there's
no way that YouTube people such as you
and me could get away with this if we
did a live event and we told people to
put their bones in a phone satchel there
would be a rebellion it would be a
revolt you know I'm saying like like
Chris Rock can do it and I think he
actually is one of the comedian's who
that sounds right did it recently it
traditional traditional people can do it
but if we were to tell people that they
couldn't bring their phones that it
seems so anti Internet to do that
doesn't it well when we when we did the
the initial round of the tour of
mythicality we did have this
conversation and we we decided not to
say anything I mean our only concern was
that people would leak part of the show
and that it might spoil other people's
experience but we actually didn't think
about spoiling people's experience when
we're there well but there was also
there there was there there were people
I don't know who it was somebody
associated with the tour that was
handling it that were Polly they were
policing the content that people were
uploading related to our show so in
other words if somebody uploaded like a
full song performance oh it may be taken
down
oh and people can yeah people have mixed
feelings about that maybe it may seem a
little you know too strict or whatever
but I think that the idea was is that
it's fine to show to give people an idea
of what you experience there but when
you start releasing entire performances
of songs or that kind of thing at that
point you might be spoiling the surprise
for people so I don't know what I know I
actually saw some people tweet hey I did
have I did a vlog and I put this new
part of the tour mythicality in my vlog
and I got taken down oh it's not like ah
well well not really us doing that and I
hope it was I hope you put too much yeah
and that was a good reason to take it
down not just a little bit all that to
say that we're not gonna tell you to put
your phones in a satchel but here you
know who knows three years from now
we're telling you to put our phones your
phones in a satchel yeah they're like
you remember that your biscuit well you
said you'd never do that well then we'll
just delete this here biscuit how about
that well let's just say right now you
know what we we just have a feeling that
we wouldn't do that but we also have a
feeling that we might we're ambivalent
on this I'll never never say you'll
never do something can't do that anymore
you said that you wouldn't we would
never do something what does it go you
go you might get me into trouble here
yeah what I say I never did something
and then we were thinking about doing it
will never do full frontal nudity on
good mythical morning yeah I never say
never oh no people say our standards are
sliding year by year so who knows well
the time we're 60 will be just two naked
dudes and you'll have to deal with it
but it'll it'll be below the desk is if
we you won't see it we'll just tell you
that it's happening down there it'll
just be the idea just knowing that we're
naked we'll just be free I mean one one
episode we'll be like I've taken my
shoes off I just want you to know my
shoes are off it's kind of like in the
in the plane mmm when you do you do that
sometimes I'll take my shoes off there's
all the length of the flight yeah if you
wait too late then you might have stink
feet when you take your shoes off
really I usually don't have that but
there's other members of my family that
definitely
have that all the kids have stinky feet
oh yeah my boys man their feets horrible
yeah that dude I was definitely only
talking about my kids and I'm like put
your shoes back on boy but it isn't
interesting
I can sit even in the house like if
we're sitting down watching something
like we're in the planet Earth - oh yeah
they take their shoes off inside it's
like ways wrong but it's all of a sudden
we're watching planet Earth - and I'm
smelling animal I'm like take it who
took their shoes off always think it's
who brought in a new kind of cheese
and shoved it down in the cow I know you
guys don't like strong cheeses I do
that's the only thing that can ruin
planet Earth - by the way it's a cheesy
foot smell yeah and then you just cap it
back up with a shoe or send that person
out of the room but do you think that if
we you know I want to talk about planet
Earth by the way so if you if you tell
my something else I'm you we'll come
back to that because I just want to
because I'm still talking about the same
thing that we were talking about a
second ago oh I haven't even moved on a
planet Earth yet okay but if you think
if we slowly introduced being completely
naked oh you were still on oh okay you
want to push that shoes then you're like
one day I'm like as you know my shoes
have been off in the past well they've
been off the ever since but I think
we're now my socks we got to go tank top
like one of us would go tank top than
the other of us would go tank top then
the other one would do mid-drift the
other guy would do midriff no no no I'm
saying it comes from the bottom up one
day we're like oh we look no different
then all of a sudden it's like well I'm
just not wearing pants today nor am i
wearing shorts it's not gonna impact
your experience or maybe it will I just
don't even know what just happened
[Music]
burped
Wow but you didn't but you didn't stop
you just kept talking which I like you
you burn through it let me see if I can
do that what was the word you were
saying was the word that you were saying
because I was super sorry I mean that is
not good podcaster form do you know the
word you were saying if a man it's got
to burp dirty speak it's not happen I
mean this is more Barisan than me and
being
memo Weiner hangout good mythical
morning no it's not I can't do it I
can't talk birth well who wants to hear
that anyway nobody I'm sorry
what's wrong with you you didn't it
wasn't clear that's what had happened it
I mean I kind of figured planet Earth -
oh no don't want to talk about it now oh
but you've been enjoying it why when you
said full frontal nudity I was just
singing from the waist down like
newscaster nudity that's all that really
matters though isn't it for men that's
what I'm getting at but then we just
wouldn't stand up it's we never go
shirtless you never we never be full
nudity
it would just be lower half frontal I
watched that I told you I watched that
game over man the the workaholics guys
movies yeah oh it was I don't typically
choose to watch comedy movies you know
this and the old adages if you work in
comedy you watch drama if you work in
drama D drama D I've heard it from many
people like oh come on me that makes me
feel better I feel like that don't watch
when I watch comedies I'm watching them
like as a student yeah and I was like
alright okay here's a here's a good
here's a good comparison for us you got
these guys who went and made the show
and they're really funny together and
then they went off and they wrote a
movie and I think that all they're all
very funny individually and funny
together and fan of workaholics yeah and
I and I was like I'm gonna watch start
watching this movie and then I'm going
cuz I'm waiting for my wife to come and
join me to watch the wild wild country
documentary on Netflix highly
recommended yeah enjoying the heck out
of that and I was like I'm gonna wait
for her and watch this movie and I'll
just get a little bit of it but she was
making a cake and she she never stopped
making the cake it was like 1:30 a.m. I
ended up watching the whole thing and
talk about full frontal nudity good
gracious I mean there was so much penis
in this movie I mean I was like what is
I didn't sign up for this oh really I
didn't want to see Adam Devine's penis
multiple time
and it was not a prosthetic now when
they cut Daniel Stern's penis off that
was a prosthetic what that happened in
the movie yes I'm not watching this
movie well you not just because I mean
but it's just indicative of the type no
pun intended of the type of movie that
indicative has other things that I don't
know if I want I just wasn't expecting
was it was it like just for shock value
or was it I don't know I didn't find
those moments particularly funny I'm not
offended by I'm not offended by seeing
someone's penis I'm not it's not what
I'm saying it's just it was kind of
unexpected and also like really was it
was it supposed to be sensual it was
supposed to be comedic it was Buzzbee
comedic and I think I did there was a
one moment when I laughed during that
that scene but I was just it was it was
just a lot I think they could have just
pulled back a little bit you know what
I'm saying they could have just pulled
back a little bit turtle could have gone
in the shell a little bit well but
that's all you're gonna say about it
yeah so you are recommending it I am not
recommending it no I'm not recommending
it I just the way it all came together
is not the way that it all came together
with workaholics mmm that's all I could
say I still think the guys are very
funny I just think that I was a little
distracted by the amount of penis and in
general I just didn't gel in the way
that their comedy has for me in the past
no pun intended we're gonna get to a
question your question that lead that
will lead us down the inevitable rabbit
hole but first we're going to let you
know that you can get link shirt in
mythical dot store you can get all types
of stuff we just want to invite you to
go over there browse there there are
pictures of us wearing stuff as well as
some other mythical crew members and you
know what you too can wear the stuff if
you purchase it
there's the Amazon store and then the
mythical dot store and there's there's
this stuff too there's stuff to wear to
rep your team that's us you're one of us
now
how do we know cuz you're wearing the
shirts or drinking from the mugs or
styling your hair with the with the
creams
call me pomades rep your mythical self a
mythical dot store yeah
highly recommend planet planet of the
earth - mm-hmm I'm not going to talk
about it now but it's um I'm gonna open
this envelope what sealed tight for a
while really really licked it okay here
we go
don't know what's on this we're gonna
read it and then we're you know it's
just gonna lead us on the friendly
conversation you don't I pulled the
thing out and then I blew in the
envelope for no just because I saw
Letterman did that but he would do it in
order to get the thing out but I already
had the thing a little bit or Johnny
Carson Johnny Carson definitely yeah
blue is the amazing yes you're right
you're right
I can't remember the guy who told the
few who told the jokes in Reverse ed
mcmahon left chris clay asks i will be
interested in hearing your bucket list
you are both very different people so I
wonder how they compare ooh
bucket list hmm now I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna jump in there and say that
jump right in the bucket I've gotten
like a couple of different apps that
have lists and notes in them like
there's the Notes app Evernote we were
both big in Evernote I'm I'm still
pretty big and I I still use Evernote
for like my personal note-taking just
burped but I stopped talking good I did
it I was good no like does good
technique yeah I'm working on it yeah
I've thought about creating an Evernote
a personal Evernote because I got the
personal Evernote I've got the creative
Evernote and then I've got the rhett and
Link creative shared Evernote yeah which
we don't use that much anymore because
Google does the Google Docs yeah
but the link personal I thought about
putting one and calling a bucket list I
already have one and started to create
it I'm about to break it up I do not
have one I have one that's called
thoughts which is kind of like the
subreddit shower thoughts like I
of those yes just for me don'ts but so
I'm gonna have to come up with my bucket
list you have a bucket list it's not
very long but I think it'll be enough to
get us started and I think you you will
it'll give you some ideas and I do think
every time then I've thought about a
bucket list
I've immediately thought well it would
be nice if if my good buddy Rhett
created a bucket list and I could just I
could just like pull from it
yep well that's what about what that's
what's about to happen like you if your
bucket runneth over
I mean oh okay I'll catch it I mean even
when it comes to like vacation stuff
which too I tend to think about
vacations that I when it comes to bucket
lists like places I want to visit like
you tend to think more about that and
I'm like yep good idea I didn't have to
waste my energy I can just I can just
harness yours I'm like a bucket list
leach I'm proud of it you're you're like
a guy who gets in someone else's bucket
list and then you know buddy Artie's
carrying a bucket just get in the bucket
one day you're gonna go out and look in
your bucket and you're gonna see his
empty cuz I like slurp to everything out
of it I do think that you're gonna be
really into many of these things and I
also I got to say that I pictured you
being there for at least some of them
and I will say if you haven't listened
to our classic ear biscuit on Rhett
Slayers we we go into if I can recall
correctly a lot of detail in terms of
that dynamic of what I just discussed
and many of the things that are from my
layers have translated translated into
my bucket list I also have a list called
things I like which you've been with me
at different times where I've enjoyed
something and then I'm like I'm adding
that to the things I like list and it
brings you even more pleasure it's like
we're eating at this restaurant it's
like gosh this is so good and then I
just it's like your face lights up you
pull out your phony light I'm gonna put
that in my favorite favorite things list
things I like things I like list yeah
cuz then you know I'm in New York what
kind of what do I like here oh just look
at the things I like now I will tell you
if I put out a list I could
beat any list you've got with my packing
for the RV trip list so I would be
really excited I'm not gonna feel
inferior just because I'm gonna I'm
really hedging that I'm gonna leech off
of your list because if I thought about
literally I've thought about publishing
my packing for an RV survival kit list
I'm sure there'd be an interested
audience pretty small but somebody's
interested very interested though very
motivated okay I'm you're gonna do these
one at a time yeah maybe we got time
yeah number one and these are no
particular order they're just in the
order that I added them fly an
ultralight trike fly an ultralight trike
is this the most recent one or the first
one when you created the bucket list
beep so when you finally broke the seal
and created a bucket list this was the
idea that did it like can you what what
prompted this were you like did you see
an ultralight trike in the air I think I
probably saw a video or a movie or
something whether it was one flying and
I was like man you really like that
dream fly away no pun intended because
this is it so this can you tell when
this list started like I mean was it in
the last six months or was it what the
first time you talked about an
ultralight trike was the year 2000 oh
yeah this was this bucket list was
created on July 28 2014 at 10:30 4:00
p.m. right so 12 years earlier us
recently added January 14 2017 what this
hasn't been that long has it
yeah I think it's been over a year since
I updated this I gotta get on this
bucket list yes so I was probably
enjoying something and you were reminded
of your mental bucket list and how you
really wanted to do it an ultra-light
try and now what she's thinking about
the fact that I got so into it
I actually had the trip you know the
inaugural flight scheduled and I was
gonna go with you were gonna go with me
and then it got shut down
it was at the and your airstrip we were
gonna meet the governor it was an it was
done it was oh right outside it done had
to go all the way to the crack capital
of North Carolina but the world
I think that's what they said yeah cuz
of the 95 corridor yeah so let me get it
straight
an ultra-light trike is a three-wheeled
lawn chair underneath so nice oh sure a
fixed-wing made out of what appears to
be sip lock bags with a lawnmower motor
strapped to the back of the lawn chair
that's basically well you can make you
you could probably find one on that so
that wasn't a very generous description
description of what I'm picturing but
yeah pretty much
it's basically a hang glider that has a
place to sit underneath it and has a
motor so it's motorized that's not a
glider because I would also I also
underneath this I would include those
powered parachutes where the dudes have
basically a backpack that has a fan and
then they they're basically in a
parachute that's a wing there's a dude
there's multiple dudes on YouTube
there's one guy on YouTube who I wish I
could plug him my cuz because I've
enjoyed his videos who has one of these
powered parachutes and he takes a camera
up and and he'll be like today I'm gonna
fly look this up Jacob because I think
I'm gonna fly to the McDonald's I'm
gonna fly to McDonald from my house he
like lives in the Midwest or something
so he's out in kind of the country so
ultra what's he gonna serve just powered
parachute fly to McDonald's and then
he's got a bunch of videos and he'll
just like fly to McDonald's and he's
like doing commentary the whole time oh
wow and then he lands a McDonald's he'd
like gets a burger and it's like a let's
play of a flight simulator was that yes
yeah yeah Tucker got yeah Tucker got I
who teased he's got one of these things
it just got one it just seems suck I've
got all of July it seems so fun whenever
I bring that's not ultralight that is it
I mean that's oh that's ultra like me
look at how fun okay it's just a dude in
shorts he looks I mean there's a shot
that's back at him in it I mean you
might
he's on a fan boat in the Everglades
until you realized that he's parachuting
and when you come back freakin that's a
crazy suppose my mind when you come in
for a landing it's like you can come in
for a landing really hard if you don't
watch out but so you know the rides
Soren yeah is that it Disneyland yeah
we're uh
California Adventure yeah where you
smell the oranges yeah well you you it's
one of my favorite is my favorite ride
at Disney Disneyland because because of
this because the idea of flight of
personally controlled wind in your face
flight okay is it is one of my dreams
and I and I let to drink die and one of
the reasons is because my wife it's
worried about me dying well this is what
I was gonna say because she doesn't want
me to die what is she gonna care you had
talked me into basically signing up to
to to go on and like like a just a
tandem ride with this with a guy on a
fixed-wing ultralight but what do you
but are you in you have this idea well
here's the thing it's like being a bird
I'm shocked that it's on your list now I
do not believe you would do it what I do
not I I do not believe you would do that
parachute powered parachute thing it's
way too dangerous dude you have you have
too much life to live for you wouldn't
do it just think about it for a second
well I
but I like let's let either make a
commitment right now to do it or just be
or just realize that you're not gonna do
it but I might do the other one
the one that's just the trike so you're
not gonna do the parachute that's crazy
I don't actually I think it may be safer
ultimately I think it may be safer
you're already parachuting we can but
what can go wrong I know you can get
like caught up into the wing and hit the
ground in a bundle of fabric my
instincts tell me that it's it's it's an
easy way to just to end your life by
accident man well it's on the bucket
list and it's it's on the bucket list as
fly-in ultralight try
and that could be flying while someone
else is in control - the idea of being
in the air exposed to the elements the
fact that it's possible that we live in
a time where it is possible to fly like
a bird that is an option for all humans
it just seems like you have to do it
once so you would do that you would ride
you would do what we were gonna do all
those years ago you hadn't changed oh I
would definitely do it but my wife you
know I don't know if I've ever told this
story but my wife was in a small
aircraft plane crash like a Cessna when
she was a baby so she doesn't remember
but her dad was her grandfather her
dad's dad was shot at some point shot in
Detroit when she was a baby and so they
had they needed to get up there very
very quickly and so they took a small
plane to Detroit like immediately like
let's get in the plane and let's go like
I don't know what the hook-up was mm-hmm
and then on the way back they lost power
and ended up basically crash landing
like hit a power line and then like
crash-landed and nobody was hurt they
were shaken up and so Wow the idea
around like small aircraft in the danger
that comes with small aircraft is
something that's just like in her genes
it's part of her family heritage though
she says she doesn't want me to do
anything like this but that's akin to
like going on a helicopter tour like we
both done but and I did recently but I
don't know it's just this seems so more
rickety man it's like would you would
you go on an unpowered glider like jump
off the side of a mountain tandem with
someone who's well qualified on a glider
I don't think I would do that I don't
think I would do that but I do it has a
motor I don't think it's that much
different you're on a slippery slope and
it's a long fall okay well let me take
you to another idea but it did inspire
something that's gone on my bucket list
which
I have said which is I want to ride a
horse at it and at a gallop I want to do
no lose a palm spring situation I want
to ride a horse at a gallop that seems
like a pretty easy one to get to great I
mean like there's nothing like checking
off something off your bucket like an
probably be arranged in the next five
minutes like we could be doing the
Burbank Equestrian Center and be like
this man wants to gallop and they'll be
like is he dying
no he's just it's he's been on his
bucket list if a bucket for a long time
is attainable why is that a of
criticality for the upset buck you know
no I'm just saying it's almost like you
know what's on my bucket list you know
eating a triple whopper it's the kind of
thing that can be arranged really easily
is that is that no it's not most things
that are on my bucket list are things
that there's got to be some the
logistics are difficult what if it's the
what if is a quintuple whopper there
should be some food-related thing
usually you have to it's difficult to
talk him into that it's difficult it was
difficult to talk him into that
quadruple whopper that we had that one
time on the show I I think this is a
series I think Rhett and Link's twisted
yet attainable bucket list is the bucket
list we should be coming up with and I
should have catch your name have ride a
horse at a gallop eat it eat a quintuple
whopper like yes you know what a good
name for that would be what instead a
bucket list starts with an F like that
would be like a good web series name but
we wouldn't do that we don't do that
kind of thing no it would be really easy
to attain bucket list items yeah it's
just like you're sitting on the couch
with nothing to do somebody mentioned
something you're like let's do it let's
do it because because when you have
something it's not effort I'll do it
right now yeah right yeah I'll ride a
horse at a gallop right now things that
can be arranged on the day and we just
do them that's a great idea I came up
with it I told you it was a great idea
well thank you here's another one sale
to come up with a better name for it
though sale to an aisle
and I'm gonna group this together with
sale french polynesia and but by the way
because you plugged Tucker gots altered
parachute channel mmm-hmm
I fully expect him to fly to us now
that's Orion I think that's the
dangerous invite I mean he specifically
is gonna invite you to go on a trip to
McDonald's to get a quintuple bigmac mm
and then you're gonna be turning a guy
down I mean you got it before you put
these things on your list you got to
think about it well we're gonna shout
somebody else out do it sail to an
island now you know if you listen to
that original podcast that another one
of my like deeply held convictions is
that I have two sailboats at some point
actually like one point I looked up like
that you're rented risky transport my
heritage in like the McLaughlin's and
they were like people of the sea you
know and it's and it's just like it's in
me to be on the water now I've been in a
sailboat twice one time it was Sharon
Harris Lake you know the nothing like
that nuclear cruise is a nuclear Lake
and there was there was no wind
I took a sailing class on a fake Lake in
North Carolina on a day where there was
like a 1 mile per hour Northeast breeze
so I didn't learn anything
they taught me some things but there was
no sailing that took place you learned
some terminology and and then we rented
a sailboat in the Santa Monica Bay not
operated by me you know it was like a
man who was operating it and you charted
family a settler and it was like we paid
for like one hour
of sailing around the bay and we brought
some cheese and crackers and the kids
were like dad go get the cheese and
crackers and dad me went down below and
like immediately when I got down below
it was like the whole world turned
upside down and I was like cheese and
crackers I want to vomit cheese and
crackers all over you folks and I was
able to somehow make it back out with
the cheese and crackers and I just laid
there trying not to vomit the entire
time the rest of the time the
McLaughlin's could only see me now and
you know when I talk about my ancestors
I say mcLaughlin even though I'm a
McGlothlin we've lost a little bit of
the heritage so I haven't done much by
way of getting ready for this but I have
a book I have a book that is this couple
that sailed around the entire world and
took these amazing pictures as they went
around and they like stopped at all
these little islands islands I love
islands and the idea of just may never
sail up to an island and there's another
there's another there's a book called
sailing alone around the world which my
wife is says this is the epitome of what
you're into this she couldn't believe
that this is the kind of thing I was
into it's a book about a dude sailing
alone around the world you like bring
this into your house
kind of like thumbing your nose at your
family but I read that I read that whole
book that's like a hundred years old and
it's just a crazy tale of adventure but
this is like a couple that did it in
like the 80s or 90s and they have all
these pictures it's credible I'm sure
the pictures are better than the
experience and there's these YouTube
channels of people who've sold
everything and just have boats and they
sail and that's their YouTube channel
there's this again I don't know it's
this Australian couple they're both like
really good-looking Australians sailing
around the world
oops you know a YouTube channel look
that up Jacob I don't you just I don't
know what it is Australian couple
YouTube sailors and that again I don't
know anybody's name but that's they make
it look so fun man they do don't they
you know you want to sail on an island
and make a youtube series about it tell
to an island what I'd like to introduce
you to a land yacht called the RV yes
what what are they in LA vagabond
sailing a la vagabond how recent is the
most recent video they still doing it
what's the date ago
one day ago they're still doing it
that's the thing I love about that they
started a couple years ago and it's the
kind of thing that you think people just
gonna give up on they're still freaking
doing it they're sailing man they're
living their life they're freaking
living a bucket list you gotta admire
that what about the army I think that
the sailing thing that's quite
well III I think your bucket list needs
to involve things that don't take more
than a day well is that the effort list
man no I'm just saying you're not gonna
want to sail forever around the world I
mean you're not you want to sail a
little bit you want to have some
pictures that's what a bucket list is
it's a list and you do it and you check
it off I'm not saying how long you gonna
be there - and I'll to an island or sail
French Polynesia okay it's just you just
do it and you're like I want to make
sure you weren't gonna say all around
everywhere
look at these oh and you know what they
had a drone they had a company give them
that catamaran that big sailboat because
they went out and there did their stuff
and then they and then somebody said hey
we're gonna give you an awesome boat you
got to be really good-looking though now
you're gonna buy that you won't buy that
boat so would you do this with me we
just sail to an island for five to six
days yes right we're not gonna get to
any cool islands and five to six days I
think I think we got a I think we got to
commit two months of our lives to this I
want to sail to an island where there's
nobody there we sail through the island
we document the whole thing we live off
of the land our our wives there because
you know they're not there no this is
like after the kids have left well
they're in college and the wives kids
aren't the why no no yeah but see if we
leave now what we have to do is when the
king of college that would be
irresponsible and then the wives that
they've got their own thing they're
doing their own thing they're sailing
around the world whatever they you're
giving them a boat and we've got it yeah
they have a bowl of that and at some
point they're gonna get tired of us and
they're not gonna want to be around
which is kind of my point with us on the
sailboat really okay well we take a
mediator we would need we take Morgan
we've already established we're gonna do
right okay we'll take Morgan all right I
got more specific keep this one you're
really going to really going to be into
surf chicama Peru I don't know if it's
jicama Akama
I don't know how you say CH IC am a Peru
is the longest wave in the world I
showed you a YouTube video of this
jicama jicama that probably might be
right
um it is the longest wave in the world
it's this super mellow wave that you
know a couple of dads on paddle boards
could kill and you go down there and
there's nothing there's nothing down
there there's it's totally remote and
then yours again YouTube videos of these
dudes surfing this wave wave they're
just like lounging I mean you can like
surf the wave jicama okay I don't know
how it got changed to CH in my Agra note
but it looks absolutely insane and
there's like drone footage of this like
trucking along like a little train yes
I'd bring some of that object a person
going on a wave longest wave in the
world Peru and it's just I saw that and
I was like put it on the bucket list man
do it do it now put it on the bucket
list this is you talking to you or this
is the energy ball bucket Laughlin and
look at this link no well when I saw it
it was it was small there's a video of
dudes just you know how like dudes in
fact wish you put this your and put this
on the list to the bucket list right now
surf you know what when you do surf
behind a oil tanker in the Gulf I don't
know have you seen have you seen these
videos they create a wave that then you
can surf surf oil tanker Gulf of Mexico
now that you only have one chance at the
longest wave in Peru I bet if you get if
you if you if you bail there's another
one there's another set and you can pick
up where you left off and keep surfing
but always another tanker but didn't you
waiting for the tanker and you're behind
one tanker what you're in front of the I
don't mean to be a debbie downer
yeah you're you're supposed to be I'm
your conscience no no you what you
should be is you should be an enabler
and in a supporter when somebody's got
is just chock full of ideas you you have
to win me over you know this if you can
address this real one who economical I'm
concerns I'm the one who saw and I'll
get in there who saw the magazine cover
of the people on the s UPS and ya gotta
get that and then we got it so it the
longest oh said chicken but not yet
jicama jicama is too big we don't we're
dad's big what a guy we're going to
chicka ma you go to chicka MA and you
just keep surfing and surfing a surfing
or we just go to Texas which is closer
get a oil tanker but I'm the one who
found something dear and oil absolutely
love it and you're the one is like we
got in fact we should do it we should do
it this week it's time to go back Jack
I'm gonna go back to our spot but uh
I'll um I'll put on my bucket list
commandeer and pilot and oil tanker like
that's how I want to be an enabler I
want a I want a steer in oil - I don't
think that's the fun part though I
wonder what it would feel like you know
you're turning and nothing's happening
like you know it's like you know what
they say it's like turning around a
battleship it's not easy right when it
went wouldn't it is difficult to make a
decision when all the momentum is going
in one direction it's like my Nana
trying to do a a three-point turn have
you seen her do that it's like a 18
point turn yeah right but got notice you
got nowhere to be a particularly sure
this though Gulf of Mexico
78 degrees I'm in a blue bathing suit
you're in a green bathing suit can i I
like the blue you got a blue bathing
suit I got a green bathing suit yeah
we've got two surfboards we're paddling
along oh here comes the oil tanker you
catch the wave I catch the wave we look
at each other make eye contact picture
this moment for one second you know
you're in a blue bathing suit I I'm in a
green bathing suit you got me I'm on a
red paddleboard you're on what colors
report cream cream off white board you
look at me now I'm on a red board I got
green shorts on you're like merry
Christmas to us because we have it
doesn't even have to be Christmas it
could be July I'm just in a Christmas
theme color and you're like this is the
coolest thing we've ever done
mr. Lewis you're like what I'm like
merry Christmas to us you're like what I
can't hear you over the oil tanker I'm
like Mary we talked about this Christmas
did I and then I fall off no no you lean
forward and you fall you're like think
about us making eye contact what is to
be like that time I was kissing amber
and you were kissing Anna and we made
eye contact and we were like this is the
best thing that can happen you know I'm
saying ha this is the best was that not
the best thing we had ever experienced
for me it was not looking at you while
kissing a woman I'm just saying no you
kissing you couldn't have made it more
weird kissing amber in the way that I
was kissing her at Betsy's house it was
a fancy yeah
Betsy sells Betsy P kissing her was the
peak of my existence up to that point
right I mean I was like this is what
life is about
we are both having peak moments we were
peaking at each and then we looked at
each other and I was like there's my boy
he's doing it too you know there's that
we don't experience that enough anymore
I want more amber and Anna moments in
our lives but that's the Gulf that's the
frickin Gulf of Mexico I contacted oh I
I'm with you I'll do it I mean I'm just
saying like the dolphin moment from a
few months back on the while surfing but
that was a good moment but you can't
engineer that that what makes it even
that was serendipitous and it was
beautiful but you weren't right next to
me when it happened the dolphin was I'm
talking we can engineer these situations
where we can both be on ultralight
trikes and then we could like look at
each other make eye contact and we need
it's like a we need a symbol or like a
extra big thumbs up or some it means
something I want it
it's like ding in fact that's part of
the series when with achievement is
unlocked there's like a symbol and a
sound that we put it in post
when we when we unlock something I'd
watch that I don't think it thumbs up I
think we're gonna feel a little
self-conscious there moment ya know it's
like I was just doing each other at and
of a thumbs up I just think I think
we're not gonna feel that at the
and I think that's gonna ruin it maybe
we carry a bucket Oh
maybe we get bucket tattoos and we shown
shown to each other yeah at that moment
I need a wink you got to put a bucket
tattoo over that thing they don't mind
el toys here's another one you'll be
really into su pee next to ice birdie oh
man I didn't keep you coming don't they
talk about it sounds cold yeah you wear
again I'm he wear a very thick dry so
yeah you would I would all you have to
do is Google and then you'll be like yep
got to do that
that looks incredible I'll move out of
watersports stay at a castle stay at a
castle it's been the night at a castle
are they updated inside you mean you
want like HVAC definitely I mean I'm
thinking more plumbing when I went to
that you know when we were in Amsterdam
a little over a year ago I went to that
castle mirror Castle I think it was and
it was cool you could walk around on the
second floor and it wasn't a lot to it
up there it was just a fortress you know
to descend people attacking people away
but when you would take a crap it would
run down a hole into the moat on the
outside of the castle right and it would
that would create a lot of disease and
it would be a deterrent for people
trying to to emote into the castle but I
have to assume that they've been
retrofitted inside now is it or maybe a
one night camping situation that'll be
pretty cool too
I'll do that okay I don't feel like I
wouldn't die you know it's different
than the altar like this yeah I here's
my thing I could die on the horse though
when we went to Amsterdam and I you went
to the two castles yeah I went to we
split up we were without wives I went to
the one castle more romantic are you
when you talk about the motor you talk
about the castle that I went to that
took I took the tour of are you talking
about the bigger one it's more up
the older one that didn't have that much
to it maybe that wasn't that's the one
that I took a picture of shout out to
riddim seen on Instagram I put a photo
there sorry to say that and it had a
moat yeah and again I see these things
in pictures and I'm like we got to go
there so I saw that in a picture and I
was like we got to go there and we went
and we took the tour or whatever but
there was what I thought and I may have
added that to the list at this time the
thing I don't the thing that frustrates
me about touring places like touring the
Biltmore House is I just feel like I'm
part of a tour you know yeah so like and
I've taken the want to sleep over the
Biltmore tour twice one time at
Christmas
highly recommended I mean it's amazing I
love but taking a tour something is not
a bucket list cuz you get you're walking
with all these randos and you've got
like the headphones on and some dude
recorded it a long time ago feel like
cattle yeah yeah I'm being herded
through this thing and it's like there's
ropes and there's doors you can't go
through it's like no no no no no this is
not what I want what I want is I want
full access I want to be here for the
night I want to be able to walk around
make it if I please like cards in the
smoking room I want to be able to
experience this castle as if I am the
king for a night and you can do that at
the caverns I think that's on my bucket
list
you've already been to the caverns but
you can stay the night down in there
I'll put it on right now
put it on there stay in hole overnight
that's my official name Grand Canyon
caverns I should prefer that Grand stay
in a hole overnight that will be the
last thing on your bucket list that will
you will be completing forever
overnight he's typing okay
there's more on your bucket list let's
make sure we don't leave anything out go
to those huts on the water in Bora Bora
well we're getting closed we're gonna
get close to that we can't we can't talk
about exactly what because we don't know
exactly what the plans are at this point
but we're what that one's gonna we're
working on something like that but it's
not that specifically no it's not that
so that's still gonna be on the bucket
list but we could it we could go there
we should go there at some point again
and we decided not to go you could see
French Polynesia okay yeah you know
which port Boras like South Pacific
light right in the middle of right in
the middle of this Pacific Ocean alright
and I've cheated I've looked at the rest
of the things on your list and that they
all seem to be like outdoorsy stuff
which is is it it's interesting that
your bucket list kind of gravitates
towards like more of a retirement
scenario which is again another argument
for the for the other TBD well I think
almost all of them are bucket lists are
very travel oriented like visit is a
more immediate Palau Palau PA Lau
there's these amazing Rock Islands what
are we gonna do there we're gonna kayak
kayak the right we need we should kayak
off the off Catalina yeah yes what we've
talked about that for freakin caves
we're not Catalina but if you go up to
the channel on the other eye North's the
uninhabited there's again Islands which
is I've talked about before my
fascination with them but there are
these islands off the coast of
California like if you in there's
Catalina which has like a community and
you can go there and I still haven't
been there we'd lived here for seven
years still haven't been you can just
take those ferry from Long Beach and be
there in a couple hours and then there
are the rest of the Channel Islands that
are uninhabited but there's like
outposts and you can go camping and
there's caves just like when you go
north back in the case and
barbar you can you can see him out there
as you going up oh well you guys we got
it we gotta get better at it organizing
these things and not just talking about
him but doing them well the kids can't
come we can't get all the key we can't
get the kids in the kayak but I wanted
to do a stand-up paddleboard I really
liked that better than a kayak yeah yeah
yeah you can do the stand-up paddleboard
as well out there because that was that
all of your list uh well I uh I also
added while we were talking because this
is something that just been in my mental
bucket list silent retreat silent
retreat yeah I used to think people were
nuts when they talked about this mm we
heard that Rivers Cuomo incidentally we
have not I saw a few of you were
interacting on Twitter and talking about
the beef that we have with Weezer oh not
a lot of people interested in that
apparently but I can't read we asked for
them to be interested specifically no to
punch again his gauge interest on things
right he didn't get a silly trick
shortcut this is through Twitter
conversational traction but anyway
Rivers Cuomo we were told at some point
does like oh in fact I think it was when
we were trying to do that original thing
they were like what Rivers is going on
his month-long silent retreat which you
know and again this is probably being in
LA for seven years initially I was like
what
who why that's the most pretentious
thing I've ever heard of it's going off
to your freaking silent retreat loser
now I'm like what am I gonna go on my
month-long side well you know I don't
want to start with a month and I don't
want to do a month until you know again
this is one of those things that as a
father I don't want to go away for a
month but I do want to do a week-long
one and I do and I want to do a
week-long one not into the
not-too-distant future because I've
heard from anyone who's done these
they're like you can't just do a weekend
it won't even be worth it you'll get to
the point where you're about to enjoy
yourself you're about to break through
to the other side of whatever happens
inside
and you have to come back home so go for
a week now there's no way I'm invited to
this nobody listen I don't know we could
believe we'll go and make a lot of eye
contact we can have a lot of amber and
annum moments it's like we're silent we
see each other every tattoo to each
other we've got to get this bucket
tattoo I wouldn't want to go totally by
myself because I I think one of my
favorite things about our friendship is
that we go through things together and
then we can analyze it into the ground
afterward hmm you know it I I think
that's probably that type of
conversation that we have always had I
think is maybe the key to our the mind
meld that I think we experience
creatively or I mean our ability to work
well together and to be friends for as
long as we have I'm developing this
theory that I do think that you know you
know it's like if you really know
somebody you're like I can finish that
person sandwiches I know what they're I
know what they're thinking right now
well for us it's not a it's not a
sickness it's not something magical
we've spent hours and hours weeks of our
lives when you add it all up just
rehashing shared experiences and then
like coming to conclusions about the the
experience the people the things isn't
that true
yeah that's the great thing about a
friendship or a partnership or whatever
it is so like for a silent retreat I I
just I wouldn't want to go without
somebody being there it's like whenever
I came out it'd be like now was I crazy
or was that crazy or you know what I'm
saying I definitely is what I have some
someone who can because when you come
back and tell me about your silent
retreat I'll be like man I'll take your
word for it but it's just like and I'll
get a kick out of it but I
that's my bucket list man talking about
the shared silent retreat afterward but
like having this tension build for seven
days when you're making eye contact in
your little you're looking you're doing
thumbs up and you're looking at
tattoos of each other but you can't
speak and then you're like man I can't
wait till we can talk about this like I
don't know what happens at a silent
retreat maybe nothing welcome to talk
about except in your own mind but I do
think that this may be I'm describing a
cult well because of that Wild Wild
Thing you got me watching well here's
here's here's what I totally agree with
this the general sentiment book it let's
just be a friend of of like you you want
to have a shared experience and I
believe they're just like a dream it's
really the recall of the dream that is
makes the dream worth having you know
what I'm saying like I I think that
you're going to relive a memory and
you're gonna reduce science shows that
as you revisit something that happened
that you basically write over it and
change it a little bit every time but
it's the act of remembering it's the act
of remembering that basically makes the
whole event worth living in the first
place right okay but and so in having
somebody to share it with and the way
that we talk about a lot of you know
Stevie it says nobody remembers their
childhood like you guys do and I'm like
well I don't know if that's true not but
I think one of the reasons that we do
have certain details is the fact that we
talked about how so many times you've
got somebody to talk about this stuff
with remember the time and then you're
like yeah and this and you fill in the
details and yeah and so you kind of
develop this picture of your past so
that applies but specifically with a
silent retreat I think at least for the
people that I've talked to
there is something there's like a
breakthrough that can happen in that
time and it's more about solitude and
like process and like looking inward and
then there's like these levels of
consciousness that you can kind of
explore is it it's a deeper thing so
while you'd want to talk about it I
think it would be distracting to be in
the middle of wanting to get to some
point and then it's
like we're tapping each other on the
shoulder and showing the bucket tattoo
and making eye contact so I think that
it probably works for for most
everything except the silent retreat
because it's not retreats I'll be silent
it's about you it's about you as an
individual it's about getting to some
deeper layer of the onion of your of
yourself that we just haven't gotten to
yet you know I'm saying okay fine I'm
uninvited I get it
no you're you know I'm just saying we
should go and if we should go to
different silent retreats or to go to a
different time because you're not gonna
want to be like you know this isn't a
this isn't a kissing amber nana
situation you know that that's for me
that I'm involved a lot more noise
that's icebergs and and sailing and
holes in the ground that's that's making
out with amber and Anna we got plenty
can i I do want to add the the riding a
mule down to the bottom of the Grand
Canyon yeah I didn't write that down
from a couple weeks but can you write
that down on your on your list yeah yeah
and I've realized the only things that
I've contributed to the list are things
involving a saddle so I'm now I'm
wondering is there something else
involving a saddle I can put on my
bucket list it helps me to narrow it
down that's why all my kids and their
names start with L they wouldn't be
named at all if it was if I was opening
the whole alphabet
did you ever been on one of those bulls
at a bar
fake bulls ooh that's tough there's a
saddle not that's not passing my my pain
test how else do you that every to the
Texas Steakhouse and saloon yeah had a
good burger there once they probably a
saddle on the wall when I worked at IBM
yeah I've done it been there done that
okay I'll keep thinking about it is
there anything else you want to add to
your bucket list before we put the lid
on it no I think I'm good right now okay
your biscuit ear I want to invite you to
help us toy with this idea of the let's
come up with a better more broadly
approachable title to the F bucket list
which is something that is about the
circuit list
it's not know that since that's like an
insult what did I say it was like kind
of a crazy yet perfectly reasonably
attainable idea that can be something we
put on a list so that we can start going
through these things so my long-term
bucket list is to check off 10 to 20
items from my short-term reasonably
achievable yet totally odd that you
would write that down bucket list
what's a small bucket what's another
name for a small bucket pale pale no
pale list no that seems like a list of
pale people use hashtag ear biscuits
come up with a good name
yeah and or you can you can suggest the
types of things I mean you can't put
things on our list but you can suggest
things right now we have a quintuple
whopper and what was the other one
riding a horse at gallop yes why don't I
forget that yeah and I think that that's
probably I don't think that the
quintuple whopper probably doesn't know
qualifying we need some more food on it
okay we're too outdoors oriented it
doesn't really reflect it reflect the
brand honestly sitting here indoors and
dim lighting and you're listening to us
thanks for doing that you know what
we're gonna speak at you again the next
week
Chris clay thank you for asking the
bucket list question I hope you weren't
disappointed and then I don't even have
one yeah next week link I'm gonna have a
saddle for you to sit in everywhere no
just here on this oh just a saddle I
can't take it everywhere you go around
on like I'm a hobby whoo I want you to
be able to sit in a saddle when you do
your biscuits because I feel like I owe
it to you great
[Music]